cool what's up everyone welcome to
simulation we are gonna be talking about
North Korea and we want to hear your
thoughts too so I think North Korea has
been in the news for quite a while now
North Korea is wrong by Kim jong-un
it's run by kind of a little bit of a
militaristic sort of dictatorship and
and something that's very strange for us
people here in the democracy to think
about what it would be like to live
there now what initially happened was
back in 1950 during the Korean War North
and South Korea were supported by South
Korea supported by the u.s. and North
Korea supported by Soviet Union and then
1953 the war ends then there's the
Demilitarized Zone and they're split
into two South Korea is now the 11th
largest economy in the world in a
population of 50 million people they're
kind of crushing it in many ways North
Korea not so much so kind of has
something to do with a lot of people
talk about the inclusivity of the
economic structure versus the
exclusivity of what it's like to have a
dictatorship in North Korea in a very
like militaristic state where you're not
given access to the information that you
need information is so important being
on the information superhighway on the
earth is so important also the basic
necessities and everything so this is
something that you know we don't think
about too much when we have all of this
abundance in electricity and food and
water and education and healthcare and
all these things we have abundance in
and even in democracy and voting and
having our say in certain things and how
our cities run and how our governments
run but there you don't in many ways so
it's very interesting to put the two
into dichotomy and observe them so again
super interested in hearing your
thoughts about North Korea
so do comment them below another thing
that we thought was really interesting
was Donald Trump was one of the first
people that actually got Kim jong-un to
go and meet him in Singapore and go and
talk about denuclearization now do we
know what that is yet not really we
don't know exactly what it's going to be
like as North Korea
completely get rid of all their nukes
how're we gonna make sure that that's
the case does in North Korea want us to
get rid of our nukes then as well
because they think of us as a threat
regardless Kim jong-eun is one of the
smartest leaders because he's able to
actually retain his power in the world
cuz he didn't just bend over and let the
US and let Europe and let Asia China
didn't just let people do whatever they
want to North Korea he came in as a
militaristic threat to the world so that
way people would treat him more
seriously and so he got with his what he
wished for which was a lot of media a
lot of people know his name a lot of
people know about North Korea because of
this and so now we move into the stage
of what happened in Singapore what is
exactly gonna happen with the
nuclearization something that I thought
was interesting and I heard this I don't
know how true it is or not but Kim
jong-eun is aware enough that his
biometrics can now get sampled through
his urine through his feces through his
DNA on a cup when he drinks it so I
heard that he brought his own bathroom
for himself and to make sure that they
couldn't measure his biometrics and
learn information about him in that
sense I thought that was very
interesting smart man to making sure
that people can't screw with him in all
these different ways so what is the
future with North with North Korea
what's the future of our relationships
with them of the global relationship
with them of denuclearization with them
so that we don't catalyze some sort of
war but rather that we figure out peace
I mean how come how can we help the
people in North Korea really how can we
help them how can we help them gain
access to the information superhighway
and gain access to a lot of these more
electricity more education more
flourishing and maximizing of their own
potential and what does that future
going to look like it's very interesting
let us know your thoughts below we'd
love to hear from you this has been
another one of our thoughts on videos
this was thoughts on North Korea so
let's keep up the conversation go and
tell a couple people about what you
learned they'll go tell two people and
we'll keep spreading the message this
way
thanks everyone if you got a good time
definitely show the content subscribe
much love